Regardez ce que j’ai trouvé au fond du jardin,
bien à l’abri sous le feuillage.
Comme tous les escargots,
ils attendent la pluie pour mettre le nez dehors
enfin le nez,  le pied plutôt.
Cette masse charnue sous la coquille, c’est son pied
Les escargots appartiennent à la classe des gastéropodes, littéralement viscère posée sur le pied.
Pas facile de se déplacer dans ces conditions.
Pour limiter les efforts,
les escargots produisent un liquide visqueux,
un mucus qui a pour but de réduire les frottements.
Mais ce qu’il préfère c’est la pluie
Pas besoin de se fatiguer à produire du lubrifiant,
le sol glisse naturellement.
Dans ces conditions,
ils peuvent alors parcourir 6 cm à la minute,
le temps d’une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Combien j’en ai ? une douzaine.
Qu’est-ce que je vais en faire ?
Deux équipes de volley !
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en réalise un nouvelle par jour.
Et pour en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés mais on reste en lien.